To have a tessellated surface made of triangles look smooth, we introduce the
idea of a shading normal. For a tessellated sphere the geometric normal's for
the triangles look like this. Each triangle has geometric normal's that are all
the same along its surface. In other words the triangle's flat. So you get these
discontinuities at the vertices. Instead of using geometric normals, we can
store a shading normal at each vertex. These shading normals are created by the
application in some way. Sometimes you can get this normal from the underlying
surface. A sphere is a good example, as the normal at a point is always the
direction from the sphere's center. However shading normal is entirely made up.
You can set it however you want. In fact, there are different ways of averaging
the geometric normals of a triangle that share a vertex. None of these ways is
perfect, but each has its own strengths and weaknesses, so there's no right
answer. Shading normals are different from geometric normals. If you're given a
triangle, you can always get its geometric normal. That's a property that's
derived from the triangle's points.